economía en france 24 añil hablando
conmigo en el estudio dani bienvenida
colombia exportará flor sueca de
cannabis con fines medicinales hola raúl
así es por medio de un decreto
presidencial el país andino dio luz
verde a las ventas externas de este
insumo y también a la expansión de las
ventas de medicamentos a base de
cannabis como un paso más para
desarrollar esta incipiente pero de gran
potencial industria colombiana ha sido
pionera en la regulación de la posesión
producción y distribución de derivados
del cannabis
por ejemplo sustancias como aceites o
cremas pero los inversionistas se han
quejado por años del tortuoso proceso de
aprobación de exportaciones según el
gobierno esto dará más incentivos a la
industria farmacéutica y garantizará el
acceso a medicamentos derivados de esta
planta dañará los estantes vacíos en
supermercados son solo el nuevo
escenario el reino unido porque raúl
porque mire el gobierno británico tiene
una aplicación de rastreo de contactos
que permite detectar si las personas han
tenido contacto con alguien contagiado
de kobe 19 y los obliga a aislarse
diez días en caso de que sea positivo
casi 620 mil habitantes de inglaterra y
gales han tenido que dejar de asistir a
sus trabajos y eso provocó que los
estantes de supermercados pues quedarán
vacíos
además alimentó los temores de compras
de pánico por parte de los consumidores
esta escasez de suministros impulsó al
gobierno a relajar estas medidas para
más de 10.000 empleados del sector
alimentos
hemos identificado cerca de 500 sitios
clave que incluyen alrededor de 170
depósitos de supermercados y otros 200
fabricantes clave de pan empresas
lácteas etcétera todas las personas que
trabajan en estos sitios estratégicos
depósitos de distribución y esas
instalaciones de fabricación podrán
utilizar este esquema
raúl este esquema del que habla el
funcionario obliga a los empleados a
tomarse pruebas diarias de kobe 19 y a
trabajar incluso si han tenido contacto
con alguien contagiado y no caer en
pánico sin necesidad daniel eeuu
comienza a evaluar medidas sobre su
deuda la secretaría del tesoro janet
yellen envió una carta al congreso
que suspenda o eleve el tope de la deuda
esta es una formalidad que hacen todos
los titulares del tesoro cuando el país
se acerca a la peligrosa situación de
suspender los pagos de su deuda soberana
la unión americana raúl vamos tiene hoy
en cada unos 616 mil millones de dólares
y su deuda es de más de 28 billones de
dólares el límite de deuda se ha venido
suspendiendo durante los últimos dos
años pero entre abrigos de nuevo el 31
de julio eso qué quiere decir que el
gobierno no podrá seguir emitiendo bonos
para financiarse lo que necesitan es
básicamente que ese techo para
endeudarse sea más amplio o que se
elimine porque si no lo hacen entrarían
en cese de pagos si el congreso no
aprueba está de iniciativa el
departamento del tesoro anunció que
tomaría medidas extraordinarias y una
vez que se pregunta qué más se puede
evaluar la moneda venezolana pero se
sigue de presión claro que si no tiene
límites de raúl el precio del dólar en
el mercado paralelo de venezuela que es
la referencia para la mayoría de los
negocios en el país superó el viernes la
barrera de los 4 millones de bolívares
soberano
por cada unidad de la divisa
estadounidense esto quiere decir que el
salario mínimo que es de 7 millones de
bolívares queda reducido a cerca de 17
dólares por mes la situación no ocurre
en pocos meses después de que el
gobierno lanzara nuevos billetes con el
de un millón de dólares como el de más
alta denominación y que hoy supone de
bolívares y que hoy supone apenas 25
centavos de dólares venezuela ha pasado
por dos procesos de lo que se conoció
como reconversión monetaria o sea
quitarle ceros a la moneda en 2008
perdió tres ceros y pasó a llamarse
bolívar fuerte y en 2018 le restaron
otros cinco ceros y fue rebautizado como
bolívar soberano después de eliminarle
ocho ceros en apenas una década raúl e
increíble ihermas inentendible daniela
cifra al día 134 millones de dólares
fueron las ganancias de twitter en el
primer semestre de 2021 frente a las
pérdidas que había tenido de mil
millones de dólares en igual período del
año pasado este resultado estuvo
impulsado por mayores ingresos
por publicidad que se fueron recuperando
a medida que las empresas pues van
retomando actividades van teniendo más
pauta nos quedamos entonces con esta
buena cifra el día 134 millones de
dólares mejor que los bolívares tenía
muchísimas gracias como haciendo por
toda la información económica a ustedes
también gracias continúa con nosotros
porque es mucho más barata
y